thanks to my supporters on patreon for
making this video possible
it's been quite a while since i've done
a book recommendation video mostly
because i've been
busy writing my own book firmament the
hidden science of weather climate change
in the air that surrounds us is
available to pre-order right now from
amazon and all good book sellers link in
the description below
so what i thought i'd do is put together
a quick little video recommending some
of the things that i've been reading
over the past year and a bit some of
which are some of the best books i've
read
i think and some of them are not
if over the course of this video you do
come across a title that you like the
look of then if you check the
description down there
then you will find links to all of the
books pages on amazon and those are
affiliate links so if you do get
anything then i get a small kickback
from that
but i would encourage you if you can to
support your local independent bookshops
because frankly
they're a lot more interesting than
amazon pages you've got to use them or
lose them anyway on with the books to
keep things off the book that i was
reading for the most
part of the past year on and off was
june by frank herbert this is an
absolute sci-fi
classic and i can totally see why it is
a book of supreme imagination it does
things that i've
never read in other books before and
certainly at the time
would have been absolutely extraordinary
to read in terms of the concepts it's um
it's kind of amazing i will say however
that the pacing is all over the place
um it's not a book that i can easily
recommend because
it's really a slog the first third in
particular like
the world building is quite clunky uh
the
the pacing in the middle of the book
really sags and then towards the end of
the book it really accelerates out of
nowhere
uh which is i suppose fitting
considering the main character is
somebody who the like
passage of time is a bit um non-linear
just to briefly summarize i guess the
main character paula tradies is
a messiah kind of figure to a tribe of
people on a planet
that he is uh thrust upon by uh house
politics in a far future galaxy
uh that sentence of that like that's a
it's quite a great concept
being a messiah he is quite a difficult
character to
relate to pretty much all of the time
somebody described him i think really
well
as being like a d d character that rolls
a natural 20 on every perception check
like he walks into a room and will know
the undulations of the sand mean this
these items on the shelf mean precisely
this and they come from this place
of course that's because he's meant to
be this like superhuman almost the next
stage in human evolution
uh but it does make it very difficult to
relate to him i should point out that
this is an omnibus this is the first
three books in the series uh i got
halfway through i read the first book
and then i was tuned out i i just had to
stop because i just didn't have the
patience to
to slog through the rest of this maybe
i'll come back to it at some point
i'm hoping that i'll see the film and
it'll make me want to read ahead
if the film is ever released staying in
the norm of fiction but being a little
bit more positive
i also read the secret commonwealth by
philip pullman i absolutely adore
his dart materials and the universe that
philip pullman has created
the tv series is fantastic and really
captures the spirit of it very well
i think that the secret commonwealth
might actually be my favorite book in
the whole series out of the book of dust
and
his dark materials i feel like this
makes a really
clever point uh capitalizing on how
the audience and me specifically reacted
to the previous book la belle sauvage
for those of you who are familiar with
his dark materials the first book in the
book of dust takes place before the
events
of northern lights this book takes place
after the events
of the amber spyglass and it's a lot
more adult it's definitely not a kid's
book the reason i liked it so much i
think is because my reaction to the
first in the book of dust was
when things in that book got quite
strange and quite supernatural i was
taken out of the story
and a key part of this book is the idea
that adults aren't willing to believe
in fairy tales and the supernatural and
how much duller their world is for that
i don't know if that's just because of
how i reacted to the previous book but
i absolutely loved it fell in love with
this cannot wait for the
final book in the series if you have
read his dart materials then i would
highly recommend
picking out the book of dust it's a
different experience but i really like
it taking a brief diversion into the
world of non-fiction
two books which i read which were partly
for pleasure and partly for researching
my own book were lucky planet by david
waltham and jetstream by tim
willings both of these are quite slim
they're also both aimed at a
non-technical audience
and i think they do some things quite
well and i think they do other bits not
quite so well i feel like i was taken
out of both of these books
sometimes by authorial voice and
sometimes by a lack of structure i will
say the jetstream
is one of the only books i've come
across written about atmospheric
dynamics but for a lay audience and i
think it does a pretty good job
of communicating how dynamicists look
at the atmosphere and in particular
obviously talking about the
jet stream over the mid latitudes which
is basically the key driver of
certainly whether in the uk they say if
you study at film school that you learn
more about how to make a movie by
watching bad films than by watching good
films because you know what mistakes to
avoid
and i'm not saying these books are bad
but they definitely gave me some
pointers in
how i wanted to write my own book so i'm
grateful to them for that
i am also grateful to some of the stuff
which i picked up in here there's some
very interesting anecdotes
and in particular in lucky planet
there's some ways of looking at
how earth is uniquely suited to life
that i'd not considered before actually
whilst we're still in the realm of
non-fiction i want to very briefly
recommend
a book i've never recommended anything
like this before in these videos
that is the happy pairs vegan cooking
for everyone pixel girl and i turn
plant-based at the start of the year
meaning that we are vegan pretty much
all the time but sometimes we eat
vegetarian if we go out to a nice
restaurant for example
and we've got through quite a few vegan
cookbooks and this one has been by far
my favorite i don't know if the authors
have got some kind of science or
engineering training or something like
that but the way that they let their
recipes really appeals to my brain
like they have a class of recipes and
then basically give you common
instructions for all of them and then in
a table
provide you with the ingredients that
you use for a specific dish
so the instructions will be like prepare
your core veg preheat the oven to a
certain temperature
put your liquid into the recipe and then
in the specific table it would be like
the liquid for this recipe is
this much vegetable stock the core veg
is this many onions this many butternut
squash or whatever it is the recipes are
super easy to follow and most
importantly they taste very good
that is my review of this cookbook it is
a good cookbook
this is an excellent rectangle going
back to fiction a couple of months ago i
read lindsey ellis's axiom's end this is
the first in a series about
a first contact event between humans and
aliens
taking place in the latter half of the
2000s
i am a sucker for first contact stories
i love lindsey ellis's videos
and i'd say this is a pretty damn
impressive debut i enjoyed reading it a
lot
i did have a few nitpicks i think with
mostly just um
kind of authorial voice like the style
in which it is written
but i accept i'm probably not the target
demographic for this
uh but all the same i did really enjoy
it and i would recommend it especially
if you're into
uh kind of contemporaneous uh grounded
sci-fi
this next book is one of my favorite
bits of fiction i think i've ever read
actually and i don't say that lightly
and that's the history of bees by maya
lund i apologize if i said that name
wrong i'm really unsure about how to
pronounce that name
i'm a person who's been trained in how
science and the natural world and humans
all interact
and i'm also a person who likes a good
story and appreciates good
structure and this book really had all
of those components this book is a piece
of fiction with
three threads take place in england in
the 19th century
america in the 2000s and china in the
20 or 80s or 90s at some point at the
end of the 21st century
and the threads seemingly have nothing
to do with each other but as the book
goes on you realize that there are
bits of information and characters that
carry over from one thread to another
it's fantastically structured and paced
you are constantly coming back to it uh
and want to keep reading i read this
mostly uh
in bed before going to sleep and i was
always just
sort of stretching my session of reading
to you know just just one more chapter
yeah i could do one more chapter i think
the book spectacularly succeeds as a
piece of fiction as a good story
but it also succeeds spectacularly as a
way of illustrating how humans and the
natural world
are interlinked and how some of the uh
links in the chain between the two are
very fragile
and i mean the clues in the name bees
are and pollinators in general
are definitely one of those links
somehow it manages to be
post-apocalyptic and scary and
existential but at the same time
hopeful and uh touching sentimental and
to be honest that's actually just one of
the three threads um
i love this book absolutely loved it uh
if you are on the fence about this
take the plunge get yourself a copy you
won't regret it i'm currently reading
two books but before we get to those i
just want to briefly put an honorable
mention in
for the quantum field theory in a
nutshell textbook by a z
i just published a video this week
talking about my experience
using this textbook to relearn the
subject and this was initially meant to
be like a science experiment can i learn
this subject in a month
and it turned into quite a personal
journey so if you like the sound of that
then uh check out the video
which will be linked in the description
okay so on to the books which i am
currently
reading i've got two on the go which are
both non-fiction but
very different the first is called
wonderland and it's written by stephen
johnson
this is a book which pretty much lays
its wares on the table in its first
chapter and its thesis is pretty much
that human history has been largely
guided by humans doing
frivolous things like playing or making
music or searching for
fashionable items and things like that
rather than a more traditional approach
of say
economics it's a very interesting idea
but i will say that after a fantastic
first chapter it introduces that thesis
uh it kind of gets bogged down quite
quickly and it's definitely not
as interesting as it goes on not sure if
i have the patience to actually finish
this
the other book which i'm reading is
considerably less chatty in its style
something i
definitely don't like about wonderland
and considerably more academic
in its outlook is manufacturing consent
by edward hermann and noam chomsky this
is a book which examines how
media is constructed in the modern world
who owns media companies how they
generate their money
things like that and comes to the
conclusion that the nature of media
institutions as they
are i say are kind of in quotations
really because this was written in the
late 80s
lends itself to politically conservative
right-wing positions
and that in turn influences what is
considered acceptable in politics and so
what is acceptable for a government
to do it's a fascinating book to read
quite apart from the way that they do
their analysis
and that the nature of how it's written
is very in-depth there's a lot of data
included in the book
but it's also interesting because it was
written in the late 80s and
the way that media is constructed and
consumed has changed significantly in
the advent of
social media and so reading about how
uh they talk about traditional tv
networks and things like that and
newspapers
and mentally trying to update their
arguments for companies like youtube and
tick tock makes for an interesting
mental exercise whilst you're reading it
i'm still relatively early on in the
book and looking through the
uh table of contents i suspect that the
most relevant stuff is towards the start
talking about funding models for example
rather than the uh several pages
dedicated to for example
uh the war in vietnam but still looking
forward to reading this and looking
forward to
uh constantly updating it in my head for
modern media and there we go that's a
curated highlight section of what i've
been reading over the past year and a
bit
there was a lot of stuff which i read to
research the book but frankly it was
fragmentary and probably not of interest
to most people watching this video down
oh it's actually off camera never mind
down there i have a big pile of books
that i'm going to read next
but i am always on the lookout for new
recommendations so if you've been
reading anything interesting recently
then do let me know pop it down in the
comments thank you very much for
watching the video i hope you enjoyed
watching it i certainly enjoyed making
it because in case you can't tell i'm a
little book nerd i love talking about
books
do check out the description if you want
to get any of these books for yourselves
and over here there's some
recommended viewing for you next thanks
again for watching
and i'll see you in the next one